The Joe Rogan experience.
Are you,
you're aware of a Elon Musk's
neuro link chair technology?
How much do you know about it? I know a
decent amount in my friend Brian Johnson,
he has a company kernel.
There's a few different companies that
are trying to think about these brain
machine interfaces and
what are they trying to do?
Basically what they're trying to do is
to find a way to connect our brains to
our machines and there's a little
bit of of progress in our brains are,
they're incredibly complicated and
they're messy. I mean if there,
there's a lot that's that,
that that's happening,
but we are increasingly figuring out how
to connect our brains to our technology
and so people are imagining a time
when we can do things like download,
download memories, download ideas or
Upload Memories and upload that he hasn't,
there's some very early science that is
suggesting that this will be possible,
but it's still the very early
days, the very early days. But he,
Elon was giving the impression that some
time this year they're going to release
something. You know, they
may release something,
but it's not going to be something that's
going to change the world because this,
this,
that technology is way more nascent
than even the genetics technology that,
um,
that I've been talking about.
So it's not like that there's that it's
it all remotely possible that this year
you're going to be able to like upload
a full memory or download a full memory.
But there, there are little things
that are happening, but every,
every journey begins with a step.
But the technology is fairly transparent
is term in terms of like where the
state of the art is right now.
It is in that it's extremely early.
This stuff is real.
So when you think of like about
systems that we understand,
I had mentioned that we, you
know, we understand just a
little bit about genomics.
Um,
we know less about the brain.
The brain is kind of the great
unknown of this universe.
We know more about the oceans than we
know about our brain. I mean, it's just,
we know very,
very little.
We understand that if you kind of stick
an electric current in somebody's brain,
like that's going to be, if you kind of
shoot a spike through somebody's head,
but really understanding how the brain
functions, we are still in the very,
very early days.
So do you think the Kurzweils off with
this idea that you're going to be able to
download your consciousness
into a computer?
Cause that's one of the most controversial
ideas that he's come up with.
So I think he's, I think he's off. Um,
based on your use of the word your,
so I mentioned that a month ago I was
in Kyoto, uh, and I was at this, um,
at this stem cell lab,
but I also went to another lab
of a guy named Hiroshi Ishiguro,
who's the world's leading
humanoid roboticist.
And so he's the guy who was on the cover
of wired and he's created these robot
avatars. And like I had a conversation
with this, this robot woman, Erica.
And it was really interesting cause I
could see that. Like if I would smile,
she'd smile and lean forward.
And if I had like a, you know,
overexaggerated sad face,
she'd like change her expression and
she can have like, you know, basic,
basic conversations. Wow. But
we're still a long way and so from,
from having full robots, but I had
this, uh, fro about human interactions,
but I had this, this debate, um,
with issue guru and he was saying that
he thought that the future of humanity
was nonbiological that we are going
to kind of unload ourselves, um,
to these non biological entities and that
is how we would gain our own mortality.
And [inaudible] I argued
something very different.
I feel like we are biological beings.
I think we'll fully integrate
with our technology,
but if we ever become
entirely nonbiological,
then that's not us either.
We will have committed suicide
as a species or these, um,
robots are there.
That will have killed us because even if,
let's just say that I could download
my entire consciousness to some kind of
robot unless it's say that was possible,
that robot would be me for that first
exact moment when the transfer happened.
But then beyond that,
they wouldn't be me anymore
because there'll be a whole
other set of, of expense.
But we're,
but certainly our interaction or
connectivity with this tech is going to be
greater. And so even if Kurzweil isn't
exactly right, he's directionally right.
Yeah. The problem would be
that you would be locked in a,
if they downloaded your
consciousness into some sort of a,
a bank of computer somewhere, right. Where
are you if that's your consciousness,
your consciousness and these
ones and Zeros. Yeah. We, I mean,
that's terrifying. Terrifying as
some didn't like you. And they said,
I'm going to make one version of you
suffer for all eternity. Yeah. Yeah.
And I'm going to just, I don't load
you while you sleep. It's true.
But I have something worse
than that. Okay. Death.
And so I think that nobody
is going to say, well,
I'm going to be Joe living a life or I'm
going to like not be Joe and I'll just
have my consciousness downloaded someplace
else. And so if the comparison is,
well, I've lived this life
and I don't want to die.
And so I'd rather kind of be
here in some kind of version,
and even if it's not me, to
something really, I think
some people will want that.
Not Everybody. Some people will, but they
don't know what they're getting. Right?
Yes. In terms of you don't know what that
experience is going to be like. Yeah.
Nor do you know if there is some sort of
a chemical gateway that happens in the
mind when you do expire and allows you
to pass through to the other dimension
that you're, your consciousness and your
soul longs to travel to. But no, you've,
I hope, I hope you're right about
that. Am I? If I'm not, yeah,
I've written about this in
my novel. It's like, yeah,
but I think kind of when you're dead,
you're just dead.
And the good news for you that though,
well, just because I think that you,
this kind of immortality because,
because time stops time
is this relative concept.
And so at the moment that you die,
that's immortality for you because
time stops flowing for you. Time is,
that's what Einstein taught us. Time
is this relative concept. Other people,
they're legitimately,
and there's no way to prove it,
feel that we have this soul and this soul
can travel to other, other dimensions.
I happen to believe that we are biological
beings and our experience of the soul
or whatever is connected to our biology.
When our biology stops functioning,
those experiences, whatever they are,
stop being accessible, at least to us.